I love a great chicken tikka masala this
is so easy follow me because this is one
recipe you definitely want it's
delicious
now first things on pan getting really
nice and hot burn the oil in okay the
secret here is to fry the base of the
tikka masala sauce the onions now onions
in now
let's chop the ginger don't worry about
the ginger becoming too fine okay cuz
I'm gonna blend this sauce blended
chunks is fine little bit of salt a
little touch of pepper okay and the
chopped chili chilies in a new pocket
missing things occupy a chilies ginger
onions garlic
for some watching okay here we go
okay I said blender now do me a favor
yeah where's your garlic
what garlic I was in there
Oh likes I'm so sorry get out
dad
you're fine about that because we're
gonna blend okay so stay with me now
take your chicken breasts yeah okay
let's cut them in half and then again
down into a dice okay now the Sunday
night project yeah yeah love it yeah
who's being your favorite celebrity your
favorite guest host that loads the great
pain hold on yeah really good I came
katrell she was good you know very hard
with a and dad yeah yeah right the
people to vena Mariah she was the vibe
is good
whooping your least favorite Steven
Seagal Stevens ago Remo why well it's
just like I know he just I don't know he
didn't have much of a sense of humor he
was telling this story about our dog
saved his life what his house was on
fire and the dog came in and when get
out what he told her
and the other side right yes that's very
scary right now
you're doing great yeah sugar okay the
dog says put the sugar in the onion here
we go
no good right sugar in the onions okay
after that okay that's the garam masala
okay the wonderful spice in chilli
powder and then finally I don't know
that now mix that up that's it
I knew turmeric yes now try that off yes